frustration in cardiff as lockdown looms
in this salon scissors and hairdryers
coming out for the last time
owner andreas lazaru is skeptical about
the fire break
and why he has to close his doors again
and it's getting confusing because i
think you know as united
as the united kingdom it'd be nice if we
could all have you know one vision one
way and just kind of work together
towards combating this
there's anger too at the welsh
government's decision to police
supermarkets
selling non-essential goods first
minister mark drakeford
denied he'd gone too far if a government
is telling people what they can put in
their shopping trolley
that is overreach isn't it well it is
extraordinary
but we live in extraordinary times we
want people over the next two weeks in
wales to stay at home
to some people what is happening in
wales though looks more about
the politics of devolution than it does
about people this is a power grab
i don't think they could be more wrong
all we seek to do
is to use the responsibilities we have
in a way that meets the needs of people
in wales and even though wales
has the lowest infection rates in the
united kingdom
the chief medical officer says these
strict rolling lockdowns
could be the new normal well it's a
little after six o'clock and the fire
break
stay at home order is now in place for
the next 17 days you can see the
streets here in cardiff are emptying and
the government hopes that this measure
will break the transmission of
coronavirus in the community
and slow down the number of hospital
admissions
but as the fire break begins to slow
life down nhs wales
is gearing up these pictures show the
reality on the covid wards
they are already strained
there's such concern now about beds the
opening of this hospital has been
accelerated by four months
as workmen make the finishing touches
around them
if you don't do something significant
and kind of shake people and make them
realize that you know their nhs
is at risk and we may not be able to
cope this winter and they may not be
able to get the care they need
whether that's because they catch covado
because they have a heart attack or they
get knocked down by a car
i think this lockdown is just it will
make everyone stop and think
the welsh government says it is only
following the science but even if this
fire break succeeds
the second wave of this pandemic has
highlighted
just how disunited this kingdom is
when it comes to dealing with covert 19.
alex rossi sky news cardiff